mais à ce moment reconnu par le
experts et la ndrangheta et la mafia plus
dangereux est présent dans tous
continents et les plus riches parce que
qui est le quasi-monopole
de l'importation de cocaïne en Europe
[Musique]
il n'y a pas de soi-disant élargi sti
militaires ceux qui ont utilisé le
Des kalachnikovs aux armes d'intimidation
et imposer sa volonté
mais il y a aussi beaucoup de cols blancs
les cols blancs qui ont exprimé
capacité de la ndrangheta à
concernent les pouvoirs publics
[Musique]
la ndrangheta est très redoutée précisément pour
sa férocité pour celui-ci
crudité même si alors en même temps et
moderne au sens où on le voit au
en phase avec le temps et prêt à tout
marchés sont nés pour inonder l'Europe de
tonnes de cocaïne et puis avec ceux
l'argent achète tout en vénétie
[Musique]
mais ce processus est important
pierre angulaire une connaissance de la
phénomène mafieux et explique surtout le
pointe avancée
l'actualité l'état de l'art dans le
de ce qui est de la consistance de la
force de la 'Ndrangheta
[Musique]
c'est une guerre
parce que c'est de ça qu'on parle
violence on parle de mort
[Musique]